THALMA LOBEL: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, and I'm really,
really glad to be here.
You know, I heard so much
about Google offices.
And I wanted all the time to
come here, but nobody let me.
So I decided I'll sit for two
years, every day, write a book,
and then maybe I'll be invited.
And it worked.
So thank you very much.
Today I want to talk about
how our physical sensations
influence our behaviors,
thoughts, emotions, judgements,
decisions-- what I call
in the book "The New
Science of Physical
Intelligence."
In order to understand
that, I would
like to talk a little bit
about embodied cognition.
Embodied cognition actually
says what I said a minute ago--
that our thoughts,
feelings, and behaviors are
grounded in our bodily states.
Later on, I'll explain
what I mean exactly
by grounded in our
physical states.
But for the moment, let me
say that embodied cognition
demonstrates our physical
sensations, influence
almost everything we do.
What we see, what we
hear, what we smell,
without our awareness,
influences what we do.
And a nice example of it is when
you examine common metaphors,
like a warm person, a soft
negotiator, clean conscience,
emotionally close.
Pay attention to
the fact that we
use concrete
concepts to describe
more abstract concepts.
And these are actually
what metaphors are.
And a lot of researchers
believe that they are not
only demonstrations of
these associations--
between concrete concept
to abstract concept--
but actually they're
part of the process.
So I'll try now to show
you how these metaphors are
more than just a
figure of speech,
but show how our physical
sensations are related
to our behavior,
emotions and thoughts.
Let's start with temperature.
The things we touch, they may
be cold, they may be warm.
And let me start telling
you about one study which
I like specifically.
This study was conducted
by Williams and Bargh.
I will not repeat
all the researchers.
I have all them on
my presentation.
I could tell you later
on about the names,
but this is really important,
so I'll say the names.
And they're from
Yale University.
And what they did was
they asked participants
to come to an experiment.
And each participant,
when he came
to the Yale building, the
psychology Yale building,
was met by an experimenter
who followed him and told him,
let's go to the first
floor in the elevator.
What the participants
didn't know
is that the experiment
started already
while they were in the elevator.
The experimenter
asked the participant,
can you hold my
coffee for a minute,
while I'm writing your name?
And she gave the coffee,
and then she took it back.
That's all.
To half of the participants,
she gave a cold cup
of coffee, an iced coffee.
To the other half, she
gave a warm cup of coffee.
And then, they came to the lab.
They didn't even
remember, probably,
that they had this coffee.
They came to the
lab, and they were
asked to evaluate Person A.
They were told that Person A is
intelligent, brilliant,
industrious-- all the things
that you see here-- determined,
practical, and cautious.
And they were asked to evaluate
that person on several traits
or characteristics.
Half of them are related
to a warm personality,
like friendly or nice.
And half are not related.
What happened was--
and this is really,
I think it's amazing--
is that participants who
held a warm cup of coffee
in the elevator, just
a few minutes earlier,
rated Person A as a warmer
person than those who
held a cold cup of coffee.
And when they were
told, of course,
they didn't think it had
anything to do with the coffee.
They asked why do you
think this person is warm?
They gave all kind of answers.
Nobody thought it was
because he or she held
the warm cup of coffee
in the elevator.
So that's an experiment
that influenced me a lot.
And I went deeper into
thinking about it,
and it actually influenced
a lot of people.
And then a lot of experiments
came out after that,
and I will describe
some of them.
But before that, these
same experimenters
did another experiment.
They asked people to
hold either a cold
or a warm therapeutic pad, as
if it's part of a marketing
research.
So half of the subjects held a
warm one, half held a cold one.
And they were asked all kind
of questions about the product.
Then they asked, thank you
very much for participating.
I want to reward you
for your participation.
Please choose either
a gift for yourself
or a gift for a friend.
What happened was that 75%
of the participants who
held a cold therapeutic pad
chose a gift for themselves,
and only 25% chose a
gift for somebody else.
Well, those who held a
warm therapeutic pad,
46% of the participants
chose a gift for themselves.
And 54%, a little
bit more than half,
chose a gift for a friend.
That means that just the fact
that they held something warm
made them more generous.
So there are more studies
done on the influence
of temperature, like
it enhances trust.
But I'll go on because
I have a limited time.
So I'll go to the next physical
sensation, which is weight.
We hold things that may
be heavy, it may be light.
And there are many
metaphors that
show that, you say heavy
decision, weighty matters,
weigh your options.
And what do we mean by that?
We mean that there is an
association between weight
and importance.
Heavy decision means that
it's an important decision.
So let's see if indeed, when
people hold something heavy,
they think that thing that they
are reading on that heavy thing
is more important.
So what they did
in this study, they
had two groups of
participants who
read a resume of
a job candidate.
The resume was exactly
the same for both groups.
Only one difference.
One group was holding it on
a relatively heavy clipboard,
while the other
group was holding it
on a relatively light clipboard.
They were holding it
while it was standing,
so they felt whether
it was heavy or not.
Participants who held
the heavy clipboard
rated the candidate as
a better one for the job
than those who held
the light clipboard.
Remember, the only
difference was
the weight of the clipboard.
It was exactly the same resume.
They did another study,
where they asked people
to answer a survey about
how much they think
different public issues
should be funded,
like air pollution or education.
All kind of things, how
much they should be funded.
And again, some of the people
held it on a heavy clipboard,
while the others held it on
a relatively light clipboard.
Again, what came
out is that those
that held the heavy clipboard--
in this case I wrote men,
and I'll tell you
in a minute why
men and not women-- but men
who held the heavy clipboard
believed public affairs should
be funded more than those
who held a light clipboard.
This result did not come out
when women were involved.
And one of the reasons could
be that women in general--
and there are studies that show
that-- are more inclined to say
these things should be funded.
So there is kind of
a ceiling effect.
That's why it didn't
come out for women.
But for men, the
weight mattered.
Now let's go to
vision a little bit.
Tell me, what are
your associations
with the red color?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Danger.
THALMA LOBEL: Danger.
What else?
Only danger?
I need the other things too.
AUDIENCE: Stop.
THALMA LOBEL: Stop, right.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Blood.
THALMA LOBEL: Yeah, you're
all in the same area.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
romanticism.
THALMA LOBEL: Sorry,
I couldn't hear--
AUDIENCE: Romanticism.
THALMA LOBEL: Yeah, great.
I was looking for this
answer too, it is valid.
OK.
So you're all right.
And we all have
these associations.
We have these associations
of passion and lust.
And we have the associations
that you said-- danger,
stop signs.
And it depends on the
context, because it
has several associations.
And I want to show you
several studies that
check it from all these angles.
So the first study
is more associated
with what you said first.
Danger, stop, et cetera.
There were three
groups of participants
that were given verbal tests.
In this case, it's anagrams.
It's a test that you
get scrambled letters,
and you have to
change it to a word.
And you have to do it
as fast as possible.
All three groups got
this same exact test.
Only one difference.
If you notice, the participant
number had different color.
One group had a red
participant number,
and the other two
had different colors.
OK?
And what happened
was that students
in the condition with
the red participant color
performed worse than
those in the other colors.
Now, I want to emphasize.
You can say it was by
mistake or something.
They did it again and again
with more verbal tests,
with mathematical tests.
They did it in Germany
and in the United States.
They did it with high
school and they did it
with college students.
Always came the same result.
When there was some red
mark on the test-- usually
the participant's
number or sometimes they
did something else-- it
decreased the performance,
the performance worse.
Why is that?
[LAUGHTER]
I'm surprised that you
laughed, because I thought
that people in Google
never saw this mark.
But some other people did.
And one of the reasons--
that's not the only reason,
there are also evolutionary
explanations that you said,
blood and all that-- but
definitely, we are reinforced
by all kind of signs
that say stop, danger,
or the teacher that
makes all these signs.
And then, one of
the explanations
is that when you read a test, or
when you're performing a test,
and you see this red, it stops
you, even for part of a second.
It's enough that you
will perform worse
on this type of test.
I don't think it
will influence when
you have to write a
long essay and all that.
But on this type of test
that you have to do quickly,
like mathematical and verbal
test like the one I showed you,
it has the effect.
Let's talk about the
other association,
which is sexual attraction,
passion, et cetera.
In this study, men were
shown photos of women.
If you see the three women at
the top, they are all the same.
Only one difference, as
you can see very clearly--
the color of the background
they are depicted.
One group of men saw the woman
against a red background.
The other two groups saw
it on different colors.
They did it several times,
so you have different women.
But in each experiment,
all the groups
saw-- all the men
saw the same woman.
And they were asked several
questions about her.
How attractive she is, how
sexy and desirable she is.
In some experiments
they asked, would
like to have sex with her?
They were asked, would
you like to date her?
Even in one
experiment they asked,
how much money would you like
to spend on her on a date?
And surprise, surprise.
The men who saw the woman
against the red background
though she was more
attractive, she was sexier.
They wanted to have
sex with her more
than they wanted
with the other women,
even though they
were the same women,
and even to spend more
money on her on a date.
In other words, just
the fact that she
was against a red background
was enough to perceive
her as more attractive.
The interesting part is
that when they were asked,
what made you think
she's attractive or sexy?
They did not think it was
the color of the background.
Some say the color of the
hair or what she was wearing.
And they changed it.
They did several experiments.
So one she was wearing
this type of shirt, one
she was wearing
another type of shirt.
They always thought it
was something else and not
the color of the background.
So that's interesting,
and I will
talk at the end about
implications for dating,
et cetera.
Let's talk about texture.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When they
were asked that,
were they shown the
pictures of the same women
with different
backgrounds and say
why did you pick
this one over that?
THALMA LOBEL: No.
Each group got only one picture.
But they were divided
randomly, and always this group
had the higher average.
AUDIENCE: So how
did they ask them,
why did you say you would
spend more money on--
THALMA LOBEL: No, not more.
This is a good question,
maybe I was not clear enough.
They said, why do you think
that woman is attractive?
If you gave her a 5
out of 7 or whatever.
And he said yeah, because she
has long hair or whatever.
OK?
And then they were
asked specifically
about the color of
the picture, and they
said it didn't affect
me in my decision.
Let's go back to texture.
As you see, there are
all these metaphors.
I had a rough time, smooth
sailing, rough relationship
we use, again.
And you have to
ask yourself, why
do we use these particular
concrete concept rather than
others, when I want to say that
I had a bad day or something?
So let's see if these
metaphors, again, are not just
figures of speech.
So in one experiment,
the participants
were asked to complete a puzzle.
The exact same puzzle was given
to the two groups, only one
difference.
One group got very smooth
parts of the puzzle,
while the other group got very
rough parts of the puzzle.
So they touched
something rough or small.
Then, they were given
an ambiguous dialogue,
and had to decide
whether this dialogue was
friendly or unfriendly,
cooperative or competitive,
whether it was a
discussion or an argument.
It was kind of ambiguous, so
you could think what you want.
And as you can
imagine by now, those
that held the smooth parts
thought the interaction
was more friendly,
cooperative, and it
was a discussion rather
than an argument,
compared to those who held the
puzzle with the rough parts.
I want to remind you, it was
not done while they were asked.
This was done like an
ostensibly different study.
So first they were
holding the puzzle, then
in ostensibly another
study, they were asked that.
And still it affected them.
Which I think is more
impressive than if you ask them
while you're doing that.
Another part of texture
is hard and soft.
And you can say hard person,
soft negotiators of tactics,
etc.
So let's see, again,
how they affect.
In one study, some
of the participants
were sitting on a hard chair
and some of the participants
were sitting on a soft chair.
And then they were
asked to imagine
that they're at the car
dealership buying a car.
And they were asked
to give two offers,
assuming that their
first offer was rejected.
Those that sat on a soft
chair were less rigid
compared to those who
sat on a hard chair.
Those that sat on a soft
chair changed their offer
more than those who
sat on a hard chair.
They were softer negotiator.
But let's see if you touch
something soft or hard,
whether that happens too.
So this is a very
nice study, I think.
The researchers stopped
passersby in the street,
and said there is going
to be a magic show.
And you know that
the magician always
asks you to check the
things that he or she holds,
whether he hasn't got tricks
and the dove will come out
of the handkerchief
or something.
So in this case, some
of the participants
were asked to check
a soft blanket,
and some of the
participants were
asked to check a
hard wooden block.
Supposedly, that was the
thing that the magician
would use in his tricks.
Then, the magic
tricks never happened.
They said it was postponed.
And in an ostensibly
different study,
they were asked to listen to an
interaction between an employee
and a boss and to
rate the employee.
Again, those who
held a hard block
rated the employee
as a harder person
than those who held
the soft blanket.
And I want to remind you again,
it was not at the same time.
It was completely like they
didn't even relate to that.
That was a magic show, and
then they went to the lab
and did another thing.
OK.
Now as you showed before,
I want to talk a little bit
about morals and cleaning.
You know, we have
many metaphors that
talk about the association
between physical cleaning
and morality.
He has dirty hands,
clean conscience,
washing away the scenes,
filthy liar, et cetera.
So we use these physical
cleaning words and concepts
to describe something
which is actually abstract,
like a conscience.
So let's see if that works.
Here, I want to tell you about
a study that me and my students
did in our lab.
We wanted to see if people
who washed themselves
after a shower would cheat
more or less on a test,
if there is anything
to do with that.
So what we did-- this is a
study that we've just submitted
for publication--
two of my students
went to the gym of
Tel Aviv University
and asked people, either
before they went to the shower
or immediately after they
came out of the shower,
to complete a questionnaire.
And what was the questionnaire?
We constructed a very
difficult questionnaire
asking all kind of general
knowledge questions.
We did several times
before in other studies.
And in a pre-test,
we found questions
that they can be answered,
but nobody knows the answer.
Like in what year was
the stethoscope invented.
Or what day and month and year
some not very important soccer
player from a hundred
years ago was born?
Questions like that that
definitely nobody answers.
Or politician, not very well
known, when he was born,
et cetera.
And we did pre-test,
and we were sure
that these questions,
nobody knows to answer.
Now in this questionnaire,
we had 13 questions.
Four were very easy, and
nine were very difficult.
So if somebody tells
the truth, he or she
actually says that they failed.
Because they didn't
know 9 out of 13.
What we did, we gave
them the questionnaire.
And, in order to measure
their cheating behavior,
we just let them self-score
their own questionnaire.
We gave them the answer key.
And we said, OK,
see what you did.
And I don't need your
original questionnaire.
You can tear it and throw
it to the recycle bin,
just give me the page where
you wrote, I answered correctly
so and so question.
So that way we could
see who cheated.
And what we found out is that
participants who went out
of the shower, who were
clean, cheated more
than those were
before the shower.
This is a little bit
counter-intuitive, I think.
Because you would have thought,
and we thought too, that once
you are pure from
the outside, you
will be pure from the inside.
But then we thought
a little bit more.
And we did another study also
that how much people donate,
and we found similar results.
And what we think, is that once
you feel completely clean--
and there is an
association between being
clean inside-- you kind of feel
you have a license to cheat,
because you have, you
can do a little-- I mean,
I'm completely good and clean.
So I can do a little
cheating on a test
in the gym, who I don't even
get money for that or anything,
so I'll do that.
And I found out that
there are studies
that use this term
license to cheat,
but not related to
physical cleaning.
But in some situations
people feel they can do that.
So what we found is that once
you feel completely clean,
it's kind of, OK,
I'm pure, I don't
need to be very, very honest.
I can cheat a little bit.
So that's a nice study,
I think, that we did,
with counter-intuitive results.
What about vertical position?
Vertical position, you know
also we use a lot of metaphors.
She looks up to her
brother, she climbed
the corporate ladder,
et cetera, et cetera.
So we use up and down
to describe power
and down to describe
somebody who is not powerful.
And you can see that
people know that.
And mine is bigger.
So every country
wants to show that I
have the biggest and
tallest building.
And it's not only from, I think,
from an architectural point
of view.
But really, it symbolizes power.
The tallest building.
So I want to show you that we
really represent-- because you
know that high represents power
and low represents powerless--
but I want to show that
we really represent
these powerful or powerless
that I mentioned along
a vertical dimension
really in our heads.
So in order to do
that, there were
studies that showed
people two pairs of words.
One was the powerless,
and one was the powerful.
Servant and master, for example.
And they were
asked, for example,
identify as fast as
possible the powerful word.
Or, in another study,
identify as fast as possible
the powerless word.
What happened was,
that if, for example,
they were asked to identify
as fast as possible
the powerless word
and it was up,
although it was
supposed to be down,
it took them longer than
if it was employer up
and employee down.
And when you measure direction
time, you say why is it.
Why is it more difficult?
I mean, you see that
servant is powerless
and master is powerful.
But it's like you get two kind
of contradictory information.
You get that the servant
is powerless, but he's up.
So it takes you a little bit
longer to react correctly.
Which actually is a proof
that we organize our thoughts
along a vertical position.
But I want to show you how--
because you are here in Google,
I think it's more interesting
to show-- that even
the lengths of the lines matter.
So in this study,
participants were
asked to evaluate a manager.
And they were told that the
organization has 126 employees.
And they were told about
their average salary.
And then they were shown
this chart, the two charts.
And they were asked, how
important is the manager?
How powerful that manager is.
Questions like you
can see on the screen.
I think that manager is
a very strong leader.
He's powerful in the company,
has control, et cetera.
And what happened was that
those who saw-- and I'll go back
to show you this
chart again-- those
who saw the chart with
the longer vertical line
thought the manager was
more powerful than those who
saw the same thing, and
with the same description
of the company, only
the line was shorter.
Which shows that, when you
draw something-- in the website
or whatever-- the
lengths of the line
matters more than
people realize.
The other way around is
when subjects were just
given a description
of a manager.
Again, very similar.
Two groups were given
exactly the same description,
it's a company with so and
so employees, with such
and such average salary.
But one group was told
that the manager is not
a very powerful
person in the company.
The other group was told that
he's very powerful person.
And then, they were told
please put the square that
represents the manager
wherever you want.
And those who were told that
the manager was not so powerful
put it lower than those
who thought-- they still
put it above the
others, but lower.
We chose the links of
the vertical position
is-- Along the
vertical position,
we really perceive it as more
powerful or less powerful.
OK, let's go to taste.
We also use he's a
very sweet person.
We use the words bitter person,
love is sweet, et cetera.
We don't have any results
so far about bitter.
Actually I'm running in my
lab now things about bitter,
tasting bitter and see if it
affects your bitter behavior.
But I don't have results,
so if you invite me
again I'll tell you.
But I'll tell you about
this study that was done.
In this study, participant
were divided to three groups.
One group was asked to
taste a sweet chocolate.
The other one was asked to
taste non-sweet crackers.
And the third one
didn't taste anything.
And they were asked
some things about like,
it's a marketing study.
OK?
Then the study was
supposedly over.
And they were told that there
is a professor who really needs
help, that people will
help him in his experiments
and participate.
Volunteer to participate
in his experiments.
And they were told
he has no money,
and he cannot give you credit.
But how many minutes would
you like to volunteer?
Those who ate the
sweet chocolate
volunteered for a
greater number of minutes
than those who ate
the non-sweet crackers
or didn't taste anything.
Which shows that when
you eat something sweet,
you're a sweeter person,
at least for a short while.
So, well, think
about implications.
I'll talk a little
bit at the end.
This is a very nice study
which I put immediately
after tasting, because
it relates to food,
but it's not about
food, actually.
It's about the influence
of logos on our behavior.
And I think again, in Google
it's especially important.
There are all
these kind of logos
that we see all around us.
We walk and we see logos.
We don't even pay attention.
If I asked you what did
you see, probably you
will not remember most of them.
But we do see them.
So there are
several studies that
were done on how fast food
logos influence our behavior.
Because when you think
what is a fast food?
What does it represent?
It represents that we
have to do something fast.
No patience to sit
in a restaurant,
wait for each dish, et cetera.
That's what it implies too.
It implies also other things,
but I'm talking about the word
fast here.
So fast food logos were
flashed subliminally
for 12 milliseconds.
Subliminally-- I'm sure
you know but I'll just
say it in case--
that consciously, you
don't know that you
saw these logos.
But they were flashed
on the screen.
And to another group,
some just squares
were flashed on the screen.
And then they were asked
to read a paragraph.
Those who were exposed
to the fast food logo,
without their awareness,
read the paragraph faster
than those who were
exposed to just squares.
In a second study, they were
asked-- this time they were not
exposed subliminally--
but they were
asked to remember a time that
they went to a fast food place,
like McDonald's
or any other, KFC.
Or, the other group was
asked to remember a time
that they went to
a grocery store.
Then, they were asked to say how
desirable these products are.
And as you can
see on the screen,
there are products that are
time saving, like a toaster
with four slices, or shampoo and
conditioner in the same bottle.
And they were asked to say
how desirable they are,
for each product.
The one that save more
time or less time.
And those who remembered that
they went to the fast food,
like McDonald's
or anything else,
preferred the
time-saving products,
like the toaster
with the four slices,
or the bottle that contains
both shampoo and conditioner.
Which shows that they really,
really-- it affected that.
The last one, that I'm not
showing all the details,
was that those who were exposed
to fast food logos, when they
were given the option, wanted
their money immediately
rather than waiting and save
it and get some more money.
They were more impatient.
So next time you're
sitting in a red light
and you honk but
somebody doesn't move,
think it might be because you
saw the logo of McDonald's,
and then try not to be
manipulated by that.
Now-- this is
definitely that I chose,
in my book I have many more
that I will not show today--
but of course when I
prepared this lecture,
I thought for Google
I have to talk
about creativity of course.
And if you look at
this picture here,
you see that there are
two metaphors actually.
One is thinking out of the box,
which I'll talk in a minute.
Yeah?
And the other one
is the light bulb.
In many comics, you
portray the light bulb
above the head of somebody.
It's a new innovation,
ah I found something.
I'm sure you know this
experience of "aha".
The experience, it's when
you think about a problem
and you don't know, and it's
not a process, you're stuck.
And suddenly, you
have the answer.
And this is called
the "aha" experience.
We say aha, here it is.
And I could give you
many examples about that.
And we use metaphors like
shedding light on the problem,
or I saw the light.
So let's see if, indeed,
if you see a light bulb
or if you think
out of the box, it
will increase your creativity.
So the first one was
about the light bulb.
So here, the subject--
I will show you exactly,
here-- they were
given a problem, which
I don't know how
many of you know,
to connect four dots
with three lines.
And you are not allowed to
go over the same line again.
If somebody knows this
answer don't tell me.
OK.
What happens here
is that you have
to get out of the
boundaries of the four dots,
and then it's very easy, as
I'll show you in a minute.
So participants were
given this problem.
And 55 seconds later,
they were told,
the experimenter said, I think
it's a little bit dark here.
Let me turn on the light.
For one group, he
turned on a light bulb.
They saw it very clearly.
For the other group, he
turned on a fluorescent light.
And then, those that
saw the light bulb
solved the problems
more often than those
who saw the fluorescent.
And the solution is here.
You get out of the
boundaries, and immediately it
is very easy.
You do like that, like
that and like that.
But you have to think,
when I saw this problem
at the beginning, I didn't know.
Because I tried like that,
like that, and I couldn't.
Then once you know
that you can go out.
When they saw the light
bulb there was a better
chance that they will solve the
problem, which is really nice
I think.
The other metaphor is
sitting outside of the box
or inside a box.
So they built a big box.
And half of the subjects
sat inside the box,
but it was a big box.
And the others sat outside.
And they really saw a box,
and they sat outside the box.
And then they were told to
solve the following problem.
And let me see if
anybody of you-- this
is a very standard
creativity test,
it's called remote
association test.
And you're asked to
find one word that
is related to all
these three words.
In this case, let
me see if you know.
What is the word
that you associate
with most measure,
worm, and video?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Tape.
THALMA LOBEL: Very good.
So it's tape.
And there are many
words like that.
And you have to be
creative to think about it,
because you have to
get out of the box.
So indeed, those who were
sitting outside of the box
solved more problems than
those who sat inside the box.
These have direct implications,
don't even have to say that,
just go out of the box.
This is a study that I decided
to include at the last minute,
because it's something
we're doing in my lab,
with my student, [? Alan ?]
[? Cohen, ?] who is my PhD
Student.
And it's about stability.
We talk about
physical stability,
and then we talk about
emotional stability.
And we talk about
stability of companies.
So we're doing some things
about the association
between physical stability
and emotional stability,
but here I'll show
you a little bit
only about the association
between physical stability
and the perceived
stability of companies.
So what we did was we
showed them several logos.
Some logos, if you
look at the top line,
you see that all these
logos are stable,
compared to the second row.
Right?
They are less stable.
And we asked, about
each logo, which company
do you think this
logo represents?
And we gave them six companies
that we found on pretense
that three are considered more
stable, which are insurance
companies, accounting companies.
They're boring, but
they are more stable
compared to advertising or
internet companies, which
are considered less stable.
And this we found on a pretense.
And indeed, more people
thought that the stable logos
belonged to stable companies.
But the more
interesting, I think,
stuff is the second study,
where we described a company.
And we asked them to
attribute the appropriate logo
to that company.
One company was a
more stable company.
As I said, maybe more boring.
And the other one was
advertising company,
which is less stable,
considered less stable.
And here are the results,
I think they're very nice.
An interaction-- those that
the participants attributed
to the more stable companies,
the more stable logos.
And to the less stable
companies, the less stable
logos.
This is really new.
We just finished writing
the paper to that.
And I just wanted
to put in something
that we are doing in our lab.
So I can go and
on about studies,
but I want to talk a little
bit about what does it mean.
And as I said, there are
many things I didn't touch.
So how does it work?
What happens is that according
to embodied cognition, which
I started my lecture,
our emotional sensations
are grounded in our
physical sensations.
And when we are
children, we learn
that our parents embrace us.
And we feel the
warmth of their touch.
And this is what we
learn first about warmth.
We learn also that when we lie
down as children and it's dark,
it's frightening,
and we associate then
darkness with negativity
and light with positivity.
We learned that all grown
ups are much taller than us,
and they are powerful.
What can we do?
I mean, even the short
grown-ups are taller than us,
and they're powerful.
So we learn to associate
vertical position with power.
And the idea is-- like in
the scaffolding process,
like you build a house.
You have the layer of
the physical sensations,
the concrete concepts
that children
learn when they are small.
And on them, we build on and
on these abstract concepts
like warm personality, soft
negotiator, emotional distance,
powerful person, et cetera.
And then, when we
touch a warm object
it activates--
yes, it activates--
the concept of warm personality.
Because they are
related to each other.
And that's the idea behind that.
It might look a little
shallow, but the reason
is not because it's shallow.
And I want to say
something about that.
I think it's the first
generation of these studies.
All the studies
that I showed you
are from the last
six or seven years.
Some of them are from last year,
so they're really, really new.
And like in many other
areas of science,
once you show this
phenomena-- which
is really amazing that
the metaphors are not just
figures of speech-- now we have
to examine more carefully what
other [? moderate ?]
variables happen.
Whether it affects some people
more than others, for example.
They never studied that, and
that's my plan for next year.
Whether some people are more
affected by environmental cues
or physical sensations
than others.
Whether perhaps in
some environments,
it happens more than in others.
Maybe to touch a warm cup when
it's hot outside is different
when you touch when
it's cold outside.
Nobody did that yet.
So we have to do all
these experiments
as the second generation,
to see when it happens more,
when it happens less, and why.
To examine more
ages, more cultures.
There are many things
to be done after you've
seen this amazing phenomena.
But still, even when we
didn't do all of these.
As the "Sunday Times"
wrote about my book,
they said some are very
funny, interesting,
and some are alarming.
Because we would
like to think that
we are in control
of our decisions.
It's not a very
comfortable thought
to hear that just because
I touched something warm,
I decided differently.
Or just because I was
sitting on a soft chair,
I lost some money,
because I decided
I would sell my house
on a cheaper price.
You want to think that you are
in charge of your decisions,
of your emotions, and
not that some arbitrary
things like environmental
cues affect us.
So people don't want
to listen to that.
But in fact, it is true that
they do affect us all the time.
And I think they have
many implications.
First of all, before I
show the implication,
I want to tell you, but I think
once you know that-- and there
are many more that I
didn't talk about--
but once you know
that you are affected,
you are more aware of that.
And you are less manipulated.
And that's very important.
Because when you
judge somebody who's
very tall as a powerful person,
and then you ask yourself,
did I do that
because he was tall,
or he was sitting
on a higher chair?
You ask yourself, and then you
are more conscious of that,
you will do it less.
And many others-- for
example, the association
between physical distance
and emotional distance.
There are many things
that, when you know that,
you ask yourself this
question, and then maybe you
will be less manipulated.
But you can use it also
for your benefit when
you do something
like negotiations.
If you negotiate with
somebody, and you
want the negotiation to
be a nice atmosphere,
and the other person to
judge you as a warmer person
and to be warmer.
First of all, think about
the height of the chair.
Think about the
softness of the chair
that you give the other person.
Bring only a hot beverage,
like espresso or tea.
Don't give any cold beverage
like Coke or any-- or beer
is another story
altogether, but don't
give any other but hot beverage.
Maybe give something sweet.
And you will see the difference.
That person will give you
all his house for free.
Not that, but it might just tip
the scale to your direction.
And it's worth trying.
It's true not only
when you negotiate
in business
negotiations, but when
you negotiate with
your children.
Or when your children
are grown up,
and you want to have the
very important, not very
easy talk with them.
And, of course, it has
implications for dates.
So, first of all, of
course we're great.
And as you see, give the
other person something warm,
so it will enhance the
trust, the generosity,
and the way one person
judges the other.
So it has all
these implications,
which I just started to talk.
And thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Does anyone
have any questions?
One second.
AUDIENCE: Have there been
any studies measuring
whether these metaphors
are universal,
or whether they vary among
cultures and among languages?
AUDIENCE: Can you
repeat the question?
THALMA LOBEL: Yeah, I
repeat the question.
If there were any
studies that measure
whether these metaphors
are universal or vary
among cultures.
Yes, some of the metaphors
are surprisingly universal,
but some are not.
And if you notice when I said
about the second generation,
some of the things should be
measured in different cultures,
and see if in one culture
there isn't such a metaphor.
And actually, I did
something like that.
But it didn't come with results.
I did with my
Chinese colleagues.
And we thought about some
metaphors that they don't use
and we use.
We didn't come up with
very nice results,
so I have to repeat it.
But I thought about it.
So some metaphors are universal
and some are not, definitely.
And that's a good way
to examine whether it's
a figure of speech.
AUDIENCE: It sounds
like the experiences
that we have as we're growing
up [INAUDIBLE] influence
of everything, and
continue to do so.
So thinking about this from
the perspective of developing
artificial intelligence,
would the inability
of a machine to have
experiences mean
that it would have a lot
of difficulty understanding
human metaphors?
THALMA LOBEL: I
totally agree with you.
Actually, it's too
difficult to repeat.
It's related whether, you say
that artificial intelligence
shows that it's very
difficult to develop
the physical sensations, right?
More than others.
And I know that's true.
Actually I wrote it
at the end of my book.
That this is the
paradox that some
of the developers of
artificial intelligence state.
It's easier to develop
somebody who plays chess,
than to develop what
a little child feels
when he touches something.
So yes, it's more difficult
to really understand
the physical sensation
when you develop
artificial intelligence.
And one point which I remembered
while you were asking.
That one more second generation
that has started already,
but we have to do
more, is research
with FMRI, functional
magnetic resonance.
Because then you can see
exactly which part of the brain
is activated while you
say that metaphors.
And if there is
time, I can show you
one study that shows
this very nicely.
But first, we'll
have the questions.
OK.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
THALMA LOBEL:
Everything is clear.
OK.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]